vous savez quoi on va appeler on va
appeler matt pokora
tout de suite on m'appelait dijon comme
ça aussi pendant l'émission maintenant
appelé ma mère aussi
là on n'a pas de poster des nations
merci on est en direct comme d'habitude
c'est le deuxième sonnerie h vous
rappelle il ya un voyage à l'île maurice
a gagné soit à l'oma tu travailles 0
ouais dis moi mon frérot
tu as vu tu nous regardes ou pas
[Rires]
0 c'est normal c'est ses huit maintenant
et ouais on a oublié le dire maintenant
c'est très vite alors être érotique ta
regardez l'extrait là que j'ai montré ou
pas quoi c'est vrai bon bah écoute voilà
voilà non on est en train de parler de
temps voulait dire qu'on t'aime encore
quoi tes de vanter devant l'écran
ma
du coup
non
oh
mais quel beau gosse mais quelle playboy
on s'adore terreau ses huit sur l'a8 la
wii on a juste changé le sais parce que
c'est comme connard voila voila est
montré où j'ai vu deux danseuses la cebo
chez toi même parce que maintenant je me
déplace plus sans memphis à oui venez
venez venez cessé mais superbes
danseuses
on a dîné nadine et nadine la dînée au
mclean on à merci seulement d'applaudir
matinée au moc merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
où